ucciso cristo bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
fan ejei quello che fa gli horror quello
che testa tutti gli horror di questo
mondo beh se non su pezzi fi e la
madonna ma porca vacca veramente
ok che sta intanto volevano fare lo faro
on line sono dall'amata ma che gioco era
io non entro nei anche in casa vado
dietro sono sicuro che è lo sapevo vedi
che c'è qualcosa dietro e lo sapevo non
mi frega te a me ho giocato un sacco di
roba della mia vita madonna casa brutta
può
ho trovato subito un'entrata che non ci
trova niente veri che sono bravo non ha
neanche provato ad aprire la porta
davanti però subito dentro da qua che
tra l'altro sta piovendo fuori tranne
che qua dentro qua dentro non piove non
si sa perché buongiorno sono quello che
significa dentro le ko provate a
salvarla ma ho fallito mi arrendo giuro
riportarli indietro gracian la porta
chiusa a chiave richiedere ho capito non
c'era la chiave del seminterrato ed è
via via che che i pendoli sono un casino
come niente non c'era la chiave sv
interrato ragazzi basta
andiamo su qualcos'altro dove stupendolo
che fàcasino credo sia qua sopra dove
sbrilluccica il soffitto però in questa
casa c'è qualcuno che mi segue e c'è
qualcosa di strano perché ancora non
visto niente
e io parlo nella mia vita io parlo io
parlo e parlo e che cazzo farlo a fare
non lo so la data
devo andare di qua chris bat via via via
via via via vela manuela di sopra e
saprai sopra via 18 che tu puoi entravi
sopra data partendo da 18 che figo
chiamate semite vabbè dai muoviamoci nel
mentre grazia non è ancora arrivata da
me a trovare se chiavi porco demonio
quella apre le porte mi sembra un
incrocio tra quel gioco di simpson vi
ricordate quel gioco di una statua cioè
la sento che cammina di sopra quindi
teoricamente dovrebbe essere tranquillo
se vado di sopra cioè non è non è logica
sta cosa che ho detto lo so però non so
cosa sto facendo
cosa può fare ai uscita
e se c'è un'uscita perfetto ci sono
delle bambole in giro a poi rimpiazzare
le bambole figo tutto a posto tutto a
posto ancora nel successo niente
comunque la casa è troppo stretta in
tutto questo la precisione delle bambole
per terra fiammiferi per far cosa devo
fare con le bambole cosa devo fare con
le bambole non ho capito ci sono delle
bambole che possa rimpiazzare con le
altre bambole però non ho capito il
senso una donna può c'è un bambino che
correva stupidissimo l'ho visto ma che
faccia buttana cosa ho visto cosa ho
visto via via che è brutto gioco di
tutto ciò non ho visto niente di
esagerato visto eh vabbè ma ton nove
ragazzi orribile come si usano i
fiammiferi non vedo una sega a ecco
flashlight drop allora puoi prendere le
bambole e le questo l'ho capito a viti
che un punteggio che gioca punteggi tipo
come si chiama e mi dice tu play però
non ho ben capito cosa mi rappresenta
[Musica]
e non ti cazzo sta succedendo lì sopra
santo iddio cioè scassa ducati questo
devo fare qua io devo toccare tutte le
bambole cosa fare con le bambole chiama
fece un occhiale seminterrato allora il
salone chiave del salone
minchia secolo rotta è un casino ragazza
comunque il salone dovrebbe se
teoricamente di quadro aperto lo aperto
l'aperto la aperto a cristo la meglio
non entrare nel salone via via via via
ragazzi si può fare niente sto gioco
aiuto non si può fare nulla
minchia no ragazzi orribile orribile
orribile questa cosa orribile questa
cosa orribile voglio andare a casa
fatemi cambiare gioco io volevo giocare
a happy meals basta aiuto cosa devo fare
qui scappa
c'è una che mora erutta e tutti insieme
va beh
immagino che io non debba farmi prendere
da questa da questa qua problema è che
non so dove cosa devo fare devo toccare
tutte le bambole questo l'ho capito
sicuro evoca prima quella folle bola fa
tutto
cosa devo fare qui aiuto apriti figlia
eva è la camera da lecce pure un'altra
stanza o hai rotto e basta volare
madonna che che c'è alla camera rischio
né forte da sole nessuno che sta
chiudendo posso andare di sopra no e poi
riusciva dallo stesso dall'altra parte
su ca
ma che cazzo ridi dov'è che devo andavo
arco demonio devo trovare la chiave
della carta le chiavi della camera una
mattina mezzo incastrato ok
[Musica]
o basta
che fastidio posso uscire di qua no
chiave principale vedi che non poteva
entrarci dalla porta principale lo
sapevo io era un avanguardista visto
gioco urca non si apre guetta io do
porca [ __ ] che male che male al cuore
come male male proprio a posto e non
c'erano le chiavi cosa devo fare
hai perso contro l'oscurità to sorella
ok ma sono diventato un bambino ma come
è successo a salve
c'è un cosplay novello però mi piace per
niente sono morto è stato bello
unisciti al gioco gli occhi qualche
malato che vuole giocare con me ecco mi
ha unito sono con altra gente che
tenterà di prendere infarti perché sono
arrivato con un camion
ok questo non si aprirà perfetto min che
in tedesco sono con l'inter credo sia
tedesco totò cornelius van canto fin qua
per voi a giocare ragazzi sono quello
nuovo non vi vedo non mi sento dove
siete
so che ci siete altro che c'è una mamma
l'ho presa ruolo vista subito notizia
colli dove siete voi non vi vedo non ci
sono vi sto cercando lo trovi tizio e
telecor di questa basta correre ma non
ho capito ma eccovi minchia nomi a
turisti siete bruttissimi aspetta
ho cambiato la bambola per una che ho
trovato in giro sto cambiando le bambole
che fate
orca buttare chiude a porta aiuto aiuto
ragazzi
salgo sul termosifone cio paura a ma che
io non sto capendo vi giuro che cosa
consiste sta roba proprio ragazzi c'è la
razzia qua lo devo andare dove siete
ora capitana porca porca [ __ ] via via
via via via via via via via via non
capisco se devo fare dove siete eccovi
sei qua con me porco demonio stai qua
dammi la mano
minchia che su mi sto facendo tutto da
solo visto cagando di sopra dare una
mano in telecom si dice da me dammi una
mano tamen una mano cosa state fa ma
avete aperto un sacco di roba
dobbiamo bruciare tutte le bambole ho
capito a destra usa devo fare
ma voi siete esperti ma vi che non lo
sapevo e va bene e bruciato le bambole
perché non solo vetro c'erano proprio
chiave fatto il suo cell
ho trovato una faccia fermi tutti
la chiesa è ovviamente la classica
chiave la dea sul cell
immagino sia b chiuda voi 2 dic judo che
sicuramente avete qualcosa di cui
parlare credo che sia che debba ecco
infatti
[Musica]
ho dato il mio contributo
ho bruciato bruciato una bambola un
tratto di sopra ne mancano due è quindi
con questo che c'è in mano solo che non
ho idea di dove sia prossimo bravi
ragazzi che squadra batte il cinque
proviamo a dai proviamo tutto è
diventato una volante della polizia via
via via via cerchiamo l'ultima bambara
ragazzi forza e coraggio ko posso
trovano a bambola in carne che l'ha
votata successo prima non c'è più porco
demonio o trovata fissare per difendermi
non riesco madonna su ca nun e poi a me
le porte a l'ho chiusa fuori a posto
aiuto io rimango qua losers nice red ren
ok e quindi usciamo a posto
e giusto l'abbiamo fatta o no abbiamo
fatto no uscita non riuscita dall'altra
parte ragazzi degli stupidi di quale la
ragazza era quella di prima quadri e
uscire qua ragazzi venite qua il furgone
ma quale ragazzi cosa devo prendere
quella che volava è caduta per terra
non lo so perché abbiamo la fanno fatto
lui non ho fatto niente questi so
tedeschi vinci con gli amici
io non ho capito niente
questo era quasi fai come significa solo
per te piace iscritti dei canali
schiaccerà campanellina privata giorni
su invito
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video e ragazzi
[Musica]